yeah i think uh the tax write-off thing
is
how do you write off jewelry give us
help us understand that because yeah so
like this right here like well one gold
is an investment it's a mineral true so
it can go up in value and it has
universal trade value true so
in the simplest term
it's like the the government is like if
you're going to invest in an asset
whether it's property or the jury then
you can write that off because you're
basically saying this is a future
investment for me to be able to do
something with it um and as far as
dependent it has my
my actual brand on there i'm owner of
the company i'm on the paperwork so i'm
able to say this is a costume fee or
promotional fee for my company and just
be able to write it off at the end of
the year rather than me spending upfront
cash so
let's say technically my my tax bill at
the end of the year was 30 000.
if i spent 15 000 on this chain i only
got to spend i only got to pay 15 000 of
that back to the government and the
other 15 000 goes down is a write-off
through jewelry
costume expense all that so it's like
the simplest way i guess you could say
it
and most people who are buying jewelry
don't do don't write their [ __ ] no they
don't think they can and they can they
don't appraise it they don't do nothing
you feel me oh that [ __ ] is tax
deferrable so
just really understanding how to like
move around that type of spectrum rather
than just what are some other things
like you like like obviously you know
for people who don't know like obviously
you know if you if you own your own llc
or or your
you can write off certain meals you can
write out certain things but what are
meals i think i think the biggest thing
for like entrepreneurs and business
people you can give students college
credit
like we've had like two interns that
we've given three to five college
credits based off of a simple curriculum
we built submitted it did you have to
pay them no i didn't know that because i
know at iheart they had like banned
interns for a while because there was
some lawsuit
yeah so i mean radio but see you know
credits cost money in college though so
you've given carlos credits that's
basically like saying you're giving x
amount of money to them within an
educational delivery